إلى الخطوط الأمامية
في شرق أوكرانيا في صراع محتدم
مع المتمردين المدعومين
من روسيا مرة أخرى ، محور اهتمامنا
مع تزايد التوترات مع روسيا ، اكتسبت CNN
هذا
الوصول غير المسبوق إلى الرئيس الأوكراني
في زيارة عسكرية مخططة بعناية تحلق
معه بسرعة ومنخفضة.
لتجنب النيران الأرضية ، لقد مر وقت طويل
الآن ، لقد مرت
سبع سنوات على هذه الحرب ، نعم خلال سبع
سنوات ،
كيف حال الجنود الذين يصمدون
أم أنهم سئموا من هذه الحرب ،
لقد سئموا بالطبع مثل الرجل الذي
تعرفه
خلال سبع سنوات إنه  أطول من
الحرب العالمية الثانية ، نعم ترى
ذلك وهي أطول بكثير من الثانية ،
لكن مع شبكتها المعقدة من الخنادق الموحلة الرطبة ،
فإن ما يسمى بخط التماس في بعض
الأماكن على بعد بضع عشرات من الأمتار من
العدو
يبدو أشبه بالعالم الأول
أعني أننا دخلنا في هذه الحرب
من الخنادق التي تم حفرها
على طول الخط الأمامي يمكنني أن أخبرك أنني
أعني أن الأمر يشبه العودة
إلى أوائل القرن العشرين في
والحرب الكبرى لأنني لم أر
شيئًا كهذا
في الحرب الحديثة
[تصفيق]
ولكن هذا هو واقع
المواجهة مع موسكو
ووكلائها ، هل هناك فرصة
أن الروس قد يخططون
لغزو
بالطبع بالطبع نحن  نعرفها بدءًا من 2 0
14 ، نعلم أنه يمكن أن يكون على
أي حال وفي
كل يوم يمكن أن يكون ذلك جاهزًا
ولكننا أيضًا مستعدون لأننا
على أرضنا على أراضينا
وهذا هو السبب في أوكرانيا  نحن
والحلفاء الغربيون
نشعر بالقلق الشديد وسط التوترات المتزايدة ، حيث
ظهرت حشد دراماتيكي للقوات الروسية
بالقرب من الحدود الأوكرانية
وفي لقطات الهاتف الخلوي في شبه جزيرة القرم
لأعمدة مدرعة مثل
هذه المعدات العسكرية التي يتم
نقلها بالسكك الحديدية
باتجاه المسؤولين العسكريين الأوكرانيين.
أخبر CNN
أنهم يقدرون أن أكثر من 50.000 جندي روسي
هم الآن ضخمون ، وتقول موسكو إنه مجرد تمرين
ليس تهديدًا
ولكن بالعودة إلى خط الاتصال ، كان هناك
بالفعل اندلاع
مميت  في نيران القناصة ، قُتل أكثر من 20
جنديًا ، كما يقول المسؤولون الأوكرانيون
حتى الآن هذا العام وفي الخارج هنا حتى
الرئيس
يدير القفاز الذي يجب أن نركض
إليه بشكل صحيح ، نعم رون حسنًا ، حسنًا ،
هيا لنذهب
لذلك نحن قريبون جدًا الآن  ألسنا مع
الانفصاليين
الذين كان مذهلاً ،
لذلك اقتربنا جدًا الآن من
خط المواجهة بين القوات الأوكرانية
والانفصاليين المدعومين من
روسيا ، حيث اضطررنا أنا والرئيس زيلينسكي
إلى الركض عبر الأرض المفتوحة
للوصول إلى هذا الغطاء لأنه
الوضع متقلب
للغاية ومن المحتمل أن يكون خطيرًا هنا تم
انتخابه قبل عامين على وعد
بإنهاء هذا الصراع ،
وهو أمر فشل في تحقيقه ،
يقول الرئيس زيلينسكي إنه يخاطر بهذه
النقاط الساخنة حيث يدعوها
لإظهار لجنوده في الخطوط الأمامية أن
لديهم دعمًا سياسيًا
ولكن ما هي أوكرانيا؟  يحتاج حقًا إلى
مزيد من المساعدة من واشنطن ، المزيد من
الأسلحة
والمزيد من الأموال والمزيد من الدعم
للانضمام إلى حلف
شمال الأطلسي ، الكلمات الداعمة للتحالف العسكري الغربي
من الرئيس
بايدن.  ببساطة ، لم تعد
أوكرانيا بحاجة إلى أكثر من الكلمات ،
فهذه هي الثانية
التي تفهمها ، أليس كذلك إذا
مُنحت أوكرانيا
عضوية الناتو التي قد
تجعل الصراع في هذا البلد
أكثر سوءًا ، فسيثير غضبي ،
يمكنني أن أقول لك؟  يمكنني أن أجيب عليك
ربما أنت على صواب ولكن
ما يحدث الآن فيما نفعله هنا
ما يفعله شعبنا هنا
يقاتلون لذا ما يمكن أن يكون في المستقبل
لا أعرف ولكن
لدينا دولة مستقلة
ونقرر أين نكون
أو  أين لا تكون أو لا تكون
عضويتك كما يقولون السؤال أو بالأحرى
ما مدى دعمنا الذي يمكن أن
يتوقعه الرئيس الأوكراني الآن
في الدراما الجارية التي يتم لعبها في
مسرح الحرب هذا
ماثيو فرصة سي إن إن على الخطوط الأمامية
اوكرانيا الشرقية